there's breaking news overnight from
Rome the Catholic Church took the
extraordinary step of de fracking
Theodore McCarrick the former Archbishop
and Cardinal of Washington after the
church found him guilty of widespread
sexual abuse
it's the Pope's most serious punishment
yet in the clerical sex abuse scandal
Seth Doane is in Rome with the latest
Seth good morning to dfrac or Leia sighs
a priest is the most severe punishment
the Catholic Church can impose and
former Cardinal Theodore McCarrick is
the highest-ranking Catholic figure in
modern times to be defrocked that the
order came from the Pope himself is even
more significant because it cannot be
appealed
now McCarrick had already been
disciplined back in july he became the
first cleric in nearly a century to lose
the title of Cardinal and the Pope had
sentenced him to a life of seclusion and
prayer which he has been carrying out at
a church compound in Kansas and now 88
year-old was accused of sexually abusing
a teenager in an incident that took
place more than 50 years ago and later
for misconduct with adult seminarians
all along he has maintained his
innocence McCarrick was a prominent
leader in the u.s. Catholic Church once
the Archbishop of Washington DC and was
at the center of the testimony released
in August by Archbishop Carlo Maria
Vigano
who alleged a Vatican cover-up and that
McCarrick smus behavior was an open
secret at the Vatican now it was
expected that mckarrick would be
defrocked in part sending a signal from
Pope Francis that clerical sex abuse
would not be tolerated even at the
highest levels of the church the timing
of this is also important coming
just before bishops from around the
world come here to the Vatican to get
together to meet in a summit about
clerical sex abuse and the protection of
minors that begins on the 21st of this
month for CBS this morning Saturday Seth
Doane well